Stefano connect and henryka Dylan looked
tired but in good health after six
months in captivity their first meal was
a simple plate of bread and tea they
were probably a little bit weak but I
think there are now more overcoming the
river freedom after they have been a rod
to safer hands and we did give a medical
attention to them last night and this
morning prior to the flight to London
seventy-two-year-old oh connect had
visible bruises on the right side of his
head one official said it looked like
his captors had beaten him 40 connect
and Dylan the nightmare began back in
April the two were sailing off the
philippine coast when the Islamic
militant group abbas IFC's their yard
they were taken to an Abu Sayyaf
stronghold on Jolo Island their
kidnappers released several demands for
ransom to ensure the pair's safe return
on Friday the group's leader threatened
to behead aqua neck if the money wasn't
paid but both victims were set free
hours after the deadline passed the
group says it collected over 4 million
euros for their release there's been no
official confirmation of a ransom
payment from German or Philippine
authorities but if true it would be one
of the largest ransoms Abu Sayyaf has
ever received